welcome to this video playing a five
minute beats get me against David sxm
doesn't have a name in there I'm flag I
mean I'm sorry okay the Queens gambit
yam let's let's go for the exchange
variation playing this for a long time
some experience with that age six the
early age six yeah that's very often
asst considered to be a bit in precise
but okay like it's very persistent here
once the trade of the bishops yeah
should I take oh let him take can also
play 92 down maybe 92 throw another big
difference okay playing playing quickly
yeah one idea after age six is to play
with with g4 at some point but i just
want to play a quiet game this time it's
early in the morning something like
something like a minority attack here
with before so my DM now maybe black
should play Bishop G Hawaii I trying to
exchange his light squared Bishop if he
is given this chance you probably should
take it hmm okay let's let's put the
Queen here after all so that after
Bishop g4 I can maybe take here and then
move the night away so that he still has
this slightly inferior bishop slightly
inferior because because it's it's a
light squared Bishop and he's got this
pawn chain be 72 d 5 on light squares to
f4 or 2 g-3
not sure about that okay let's move and
don't make a big deal out of it spending
lots of time yeah ok I want to play b4
b5 for the minority attack i'm going to
start this right away not losing any
time there okay mmm yeah I can play I
can play a form or i can play night a
for intending night to see five I think
I'll I go with that using those own
slightly weakened dark squares but like
might be able to play um be five but ok
he's doing something entirely different
I'm going to use this opportunity to put
the night to see five yeah he must
protect him should I play Bishop f5 when
he my pledge for really if I go h3 here
probably will play play the bishop bag
hy i always have night f5 it's not not
not very dangerous really at least i
think yeah of course he gets his bishop
traded now but this is not a bad setup
the bishop on f5 is doing some useful
things it puts some pressure here on g7
it prevents h4 h 3 it does not look bad
for me um
okay so look see one just just improving
yeah 2 D 3 or 2 h 3 mm I go to h3 he
might play night age 7 and 95 mm but he
might play the pawn to h3 if i go to d3
oh my plane I g-form hmm 94 is
especially especially problematic that's
not so great really but not much to do
maybe not much not much else to do then
one of those tools Bishop d3 94 was
really awkward okay his plane it4 may be
intending to go to g5 okay i will take
you anyway it's not much mud LMAO not
much else in any case now gets be five
in what I plenty all along with the
minority attack yeah there is some
pressure on c6 how does he even cover it
I don't see that at the moment rook c8 I
mean the bishop has some useful Ralia on
NH 3 now I don't think that nightie for
was very good probably should have gone
i th 795 this is probably a good
position for me now if he takes on b5 I
can also okays giving it's not giving
away this pawn but almost I think I need
to do this here anyway so let's let's
get ahead and lay it make sure that my
back rank is not so weak anymore and I
still have those those threats
okay here I thought Quincy seven is good
I think it is good yes let's try to
force a queen trade the upcoming
structure is very favorable and I don't
know it can maybe play Queen to f6 but
it's the only move I see that that make
some sense and prevents the Queen trade
mean a 6 mm looks weird yeah Trading
Queens really looks terrible those three
parts we probably all fall at least two
of them yeah does this this was possible
really okay i was thinking Queen f4
maybe do that and do it quickly if he is
moving the Queen I have rook c5 and then
take on be 545 yeah that's a good
structure very sound structure Bishop 1h
3 is nicely covering c8 and i will get i
would get those points now let's scrap
here first d5 hangs so it does not have
time for f5 and now yeah the simple
decision is to just take and play rook
c7 and I guess I'll do that I'm trying
to play as simple as possible at the end
I will win a pawn and I have a rook
endgame with a superior structure it's
not not an easy we know anything but
it's still very very favorable maybe
it's not easy to win at all to be
perfectly perfectly honest
I can try to play for f3e 4-ply trying
to try to play from mating attack and
Jack not easy f 34 if I have seven major
this kind of this I know yes rookie 2 mm
I forgot about that okay if I go you for
now yeah that's that's not really really
convincing is it not really
I see really no way to play this for
when that was stupid this book and game
wasn't there wasn't what I should have
done okay maybe I can check can regroup
here somehow and make some progress
later okay I probably won't make any
headway without this check check I don't
know probably it's a draw check my
humming for shine sunshine I need to
switch that off really yeah this was a
very bad I mean the whole game was
pretty okay but I really probably
shouldn't shouldn't do this
transformation that was not very precise
simply I look I need to play rook b6
yeah yeah yeahs root b 6 is much
stronger or Bishop g2 nah what a bad end
game play hmm I was just thinking okay
let's let's take this pawn on b7 but the
upcoming endgame is really not not
convincing at all especially because the
black king gets activated this is what I
didn't really see when I took them I I
didn't really take into account that he
has b6 and manages to lose the pawn on
d6 so that actually after this he gets
the king in and this is this is simply
not enough simply not enough that was
bad so I shouldn't take what I should do
is a play should play this which
basically picks up the pawn or rugby 6
is also much better another idea is to
now threaten
to grab on e6 and after that I can play
a move like 97 Luke c70 for example and
then take it I mean this is an entirely
different thing now I haven't repaired
repaired his his pawn structure he has
still can hang on and of course and
tried to fight but here I'm much much
better compared to the game in this in
this upcoming in this coming rook
endgame I pretty much have nothing um I
was thinking that I could maybe do
something like that but it's not leading
to much and I really have nothing here
yeah with little touch i played this
this chess remove which which pretty
much gives up any hope for an edge but
okay i can i can continue but there is
very little hope check that anything is
happening even what black did was okay
he probably didn't need to allow that
but i have no way forward here early
yeah that was a bad sped way to play
here this Bishop takes c6 okay thanks
for watching